From Hidden Brain Media, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is my unsung hero. Stories where one person reached out to help another in a time of need. Hello, my unsung hero story is from a doctor I heard over 30 years ago. That's an unsung hero because he rarely got any recognition for his huge heart and his unselfish action. You mean the world to me and I can't thank you enough. Today's story comes from Justin Horner.
来自隐蔽大脑传媒，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是我的无名英雄。讲述一个人在他人需要时伸出援手的故事。大家好，我的无名英雄故事来自我30多年前听到的一位医生。他是一个无名英雄，因为他博大的胸怀和无私的举动很少得到认可。你对我很重要，我对你感激不尽。今天的故事来自贾斯汀·霍纳。
In 2011, Justin was driving down a busy freeway in Portland, Oregon when his Taya Blua. Justin was driving down a busy freeway in Portland, Oregon, when his tire blew up. He had a spare, but he needed a jack. So he made some big signs that said he needed help. Put them in his car window and waited on the side of the road. For three hours, no one stopped. Then right around the time he was about to give up and try to hitchhike, a van pulled up. Then, right around the time he was about to give up and try to hitchhike a van polder. And outbounded, I guess what I would call my unsung heroes.
2011年，贾斯汀正在俄勒冈州波特兰市一条繁忙的高速公路上开车，这时他的轮胎爆了。贾斯汀正在俄勒冈州波特兰市一条繁忙的高速公路上开车，这时他的轮胎爆了。他有一个备胎，但他需要一个千斤顶。于是他做了几个大牌子，上面写着他需要帮助。把它们放在车窗上，在路边等待。三个小时过去了，没有人停下来。就在他快要放弃并试图搭便车的时候，一辆面包车停了下来。然后，就在他快要放弃并试图搭便车的时候，一辆面包车停了下来。从里面走出来，我想我可以说我的无名英雄。
It was a migrant working family, agricultural family that was in Oregon picking fruit. And they didn't speak any English, say for their youngest daughter, who was probably like five or six. She spoke a bit of English and they just immediately said about helping. They came over, they he unloaded his jack and it was pretty obvious from the get go that the jack was going to be too small, but the man was just like undeterred. The man seemed to know exactly what to do next. First, he went back to his van and returned with a saw. Then he found a big log on the side of the road
这是一个移民工薪家庭，一个在俄勒冈州摘水果的农业家庭。他们不会说英语，除了他们的小女儿，她可能五六岁大。她会说一点英语，他们马上就开始帮忙。他们走过来，他卸下千斤顶，从一开始就很明显，这个千斤顶太小了，但那个人毫不退缩。那个人似乎确切地知道下一步该做什么。首先，他回到面包车里，拿回一把锯子。然后他在路边发现了一根大圆木
and cut a section out of it. Together, Justin and the man rolled the wood over to the car, put it under the jack, and managed to lift the car. Now, they just had to remove the busted wheel. So the man gave Justin his lug wrench and Justin started twisting the bolts out of the tire. But the wrench was flimsy and before he knew it, it was broken. I just cheered the head clean off of it. And the guy just took it from me and he immediately gave it to his wife.
并从上面锯下一段。贾斯汀和那个人一起把木头滚到车旁，放在千斤顶下面，设法把车抬了起来。现在，他们只需要卸下坏掉的车轮。于是那个人把他的轮扳手交给了贾斯汀，贾斯汀开始把轮胎上的螺栓拧下来。但扳手很不结实，还没等他反应过来，它就断了。我把头都给掰断了。那个人直接从我手里拿过去，立刻交给了他的妻子。
They had a short conversation and she got in the van and took off. It was explained to me that she was going to go replace it and she was back in no time. When she returned we were able to get the wheel off and we were able to get the spare on and it was just amazing. And when we got finished, she even produced this big water jug, but what you would dump on a coach at the end of a winning football game. And we were able to wash our hands. And I just thanked them and thanked them and thanked them. And I tried to give her money.
他们简短地交谈了一下，她上车开走了。向我解释说，她要去换一个，不一会儿她就回来了。当她回来时，我们卸下了车轮，装上了备胎，这真是太神奇了。当我们弄完时，她甚至拿出了一个大水壶，就像你在赢得一场橄榄球比赛后泼在教练身上那种。我们可以洗手了。我向他们道谢、道谢、再道谢。我试图给她钱。
I only had a $20 bill. And I just thought, you drove around. You've been here for an hour. It's the least I could do. And she just wouldn't take it. And, you know, I understood, you know, they just wanted to help, but I was really adamant about giving them this money. I eventually just kind of put it in her hand. And I just said, you know, there's no way I'm taking this money and I kind of walked away. And it was when I walked away that their little girl called out and she asked me if I was hungry. And in fact, I was starving. I was on my way to lunch when I had the blowout.
我只有一张20美元的钞票。我想，你开车绕了这么久。你已经在这里一个小时了。这是我能做的最起码的事。但她就是不要。而且，你知道的，我理解，你知道，他们只是想帮忙，但我真的很坚持要把这钱给她。最后我还是把钱塞到了她手里。我说，你知道，我绝不能要这钱，然后我就走开了。就在我走开的时候，他们的小女儿喊住我，问我饿不饿。事实上，我饿极了。爆胎时我正要去吃午饭。
And she brought me a tamale from their cooler. And thank me and I thanked her and she jumped in the car and they just took off. And as they're trying to get into traffic, I unwrap the tamale and my money is in the tamale. Like they can unwrap the tamale, they'd put the 20 in and then they'd wrap it back up. And I just immediately got out of the car and I run up to the van,
她从保温箱里拿了一个玉米粉蒸肉给我。谢谢我，我谢谢她，她跳上车，他们就出发了。就在他们试图汇入车流时，我打开玉米粉蒸肉，发现我的钱在里面。就像他们可以打开玉米粉蒸肉，把20块钱放进去，然后重新包好一样。我立刻下了车，向面包车跑去，
he's still trying to get into traffic and he rolls down his window. He sees me coming and he's just shaking his head and I keep saying like, poor for vor, poor for vor, I'm holding the bill out. And he just kind of puts his hand up and he just, you know, with this big smile on his face, he just says, today you tomorrow me.
他还在试图汇入车流，并摇下了车窗。他看到我走过来，只是摇了摇头，我一直说“波尔·福·沃”（por favor），挥舞着手中的钞票。他只是把手抬起来，带着一脸灿烂的微笑说：“今天是你，明天是我。”
And he gave me a wave and you rolled up the window and Drove on to the road and took off The last thing I saw was a daughter in the back just waving goodbye and I'd never saw him again It's weird. It's it It just seemed like some you know chicken soup for the soul kind of thing, right? Today, you tomorrow, me, like, it could have been you. It could have been me. But when you start taking it apart, it's, it's kind of big.
他向我挥了挥手，摇上车窗，开车驶上公路走了。我看到的最后景象是后座的小女儿在挥手告别，我再也没有见过他。这很奇怪。这就像是某种《心灵鸡汤》似的东西，对吧？今天是你，明天是我，就像，可能轮到你，也可能轮到我。但当你仔细剖析时，这意义重大。
I think at the end of the day, it just shows you that everyone can be vulnerable in a given situation, and that everybody needs help. Listen to Justin Horner, is from Portland, Oregon. If you enjoy this episode, be sure to check out our new podcast, My Unsung Hero, where you'll find more stories like this that recognize people who step up in a moment of need. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想归根结底，它向人们表明，在特定情况下每个人都可能是脆弱的，每个人都需要帮助。听众朋友，刚才的故事来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的贾斯汀·霍纳。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必查看我们的新播客《我的无名英雄》，在那里你会发现更多这样的故事，向那些在需要时挺身而出的人致敬。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回头见。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。